[ELECTRONIC MUSIC PLAYING]
JOANNA SMITH: Hey, guys.
I'm Joanna Smith.
And I'm a Developer Programs
Engineer here at Google+.
And today I brought my two
favorite desk mates to help me
present some upcoming changes
to the Activities API.
CHRIS CARTLAND: So, hi.
I'm Chris Cartland.
And I'm a Developer
Programs Engineer
on the Google+ platform.
GUS CLASS: Hi.
I'm Gus Class.
And I'm a Developer Advocate.
And I work with Joanna
and Cartland.
JOANNA SMITH: So many of
you might have seen my
announcement that I sent out
about two weeks ago and then
reposted last week.
So we've got a few small changes
that are coming very
soon, actually.
So we want to talk to you
about these changes and
actually show you really like
what the difference is and
help you get prepared
for them.
So, Cartland, take it away.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Great.
So there's going to be some
changes coming out with the
way that Activities return photo
albums and articles.
They're very simple changes.
You'll still be able to
get the same content.
But we're packaging them
up in a nicer way.
And we're going to talk
about that right now.
We're going to first show you
what it looks like today and
then show you what it
looks like soon.
And then we'll show you what
happens if you don't update
your application and the API
changes to show the same
content but in a slightly
different format.
JOANNA SMITH: And one thing is,
don't worry about having
to take notes and write all this
stuff down because, of
course, we've made it
available online.
You can find the link on the
Google+ event, the GDL event,
or the YouTube event, straight
back to my email where I
discuss these changes
in-depth.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Great.
So this is just a simple demo
application that has two
pieces of JSON.
One is the old response that
you can get today.
And one is the new that
you will get once
the API rolls out.
So if you render the old
response, what you'll get is a
series of objects, which starts
with an album which
contains the title, which here
is Random Album, which is a
very creative name.
Great job, Gus.
And then after that, you get
a series of objects which
represent the images.
And that contains a URL for an
image that we fetched here and
then also a full-sized image.
GUS CLASS: And so what you're
seeing here is just a full
album and all the attachments
that are associated with it.
And these are all just images.
And then at the very end is an
article as well, Cartland.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Great.
So this last one here
at the bottom is a
different type of activity.
It's an article.
Again, it has an object
for the title,
which we've shown here--
Fancy Scrolling Sites--
and then an image URL that we
then just put on the web page.
So that's what it looks
like today.
The new response is going to
take the images within the
activity and put them actually
inside the object in the JSON.
So rather than returning a
separate object with the URLs,
we're just going to package that
in where they logically
make sense.
So if I run the new version,
we still get the same
information.
The same photos are returned.
However, in the JSON, this
album is just a field.
The name of the album--
sorry-- is a field.
And then within that, there
are thumbnails.
And this list of thumbnails
contains URLs for the images
that you want to retrieve.
JOANNA SMITH: So, Cartland,
if all it is is a list of
thumbnails, why does the first
one look like a full image
instead of a thumbnail?
CHRIS CARTLAND: Good question.
So the first image that is
returned is actually the album
cover, so it's treated
as another thumbnail.
But by default, it will return
larger than the others just to
make it convenient to show
the cover separately.
JOANNA SMITH: Oh, OK.
CHRIS CARTLAND: And again, at
the bottom, the article again
returns the title.
And then within the JSON
object is the image.
And the image again has a
URL that you can fetch.
So all of the content
is the same.
But the new format is
better packaged.
So quickly, I want to show you
what happens if we take the
code from the new API, and we're
going to put it into the
old function and see
what happens.
So I just copied the new JSON
into the old function.
And I'm going to render it.
And you'll see that none of
the images showed up.
And that's not because the
images aren't there and you're
not getting them anymore.
It's just that the information's
been moved
around into a different place.
We'll document how you can make
these updates so that
when we say render new, they'll
still look beautiful.
GUS CLASS: Great
demo, Cartland.
So yeah, with these upcoming
changes, it probably won't
break everything that
you've done.
But you'll have to be aware that
if images stop showing
up, you will have to make some
revisions to your code.
JOANNA SMITH: OK, so when you
were illustrating this, the
JavaScript that we were using to
form these tools, was that
anything special that's
available online?
Or was that just like
the equivalent of an
app that you created?
GUS CLASS: So the JavaScript's
actually really simple.
I would hardly call it an app.
All it does is parse the JSON.
And then it actually retrieves
attributes from the object
that's parsed.
JOANNA SMITH: OK.
And you used different
JavaScript for each of the
buttons, correct?
GUS CLASS: Exactly.
JOANNA SMITH: So those are the
changes that we need to
highlighting?
GUS CLASS: OK.
Yeah, sure.
So, yeah, there's a render
old button and then
a render new button.
And those actually will access
those objects in different
ways because of the changes with
the attachments within
the images.
JOANNA SMITH: OK.
Cool.
GUS CLASS: So, while we listen
for questions, I'll show you
another app that I've just
been playing around with.
And all this does is it uses the
Activities List API, and
then actually retrieves items
that you search for, and then
graphs them over time.
So right now is probably a great
time to ask questions if
you guys have them for
our Office Hours.
And Joanna will be--
JOANNA SMITH: Monitoring
as always.
GUS CLASS: Monitoring
as they go.
JOANNA SMITH: I have two
questions already.
But we're going to go ahead and
wait for more to come in.
GUS CLASS: Cool.
So here is actually-- like, I
perform this query, and then I
render this graph.
And then you can actually see
the count of results as they
appear over time in my graph.
And I've got another fun thing
that I added to it where I
actually render all of the
activity within the post by
type on this graph.
So here you can see in the
middle of the post is this
object that's note.
And it doesn't like to render.
But, yeah, if you actually
look, there's various
attributes that I'm pulling to
kind of bridge together the
little piece of this
as a graph.
So because I'm just using the
display name property, this
app would not be affected by
the attachments changes.
JOANNA SMITH: Oh, cool.
So this is an example
of how small these
changes are, right?
GUS CLASS: Yep.
JOANNA SMITH: It doesn't
affect anything else?
GUS CLASS: Exactly.
JOANNA SMITH: Awesome.
OK, so one question that I've
actually heard multiple times
throughout the last two weeks
that I'm really glad was asked
on the G+ event was
asked by Gerwin.
And he wanted to know--
is the album attachment
currently returns the first
few photos, about 14 of them.
And he wanted to know if now if
he posted a bigger album,
this will change,
and it'll start
returning the entire album.
And I think that this is
actually a further reaching
question than we realized
because these changes don't
actually affect any behavior
of the API.
We are only adjusting where data
is stored and how you can
retrieve it.
So we're cleaning
things up a bit.
We're not actually modifying
anything major.
Is that correct, Gus?
GUS CLASS: Yep.
There were no significant
changes such as that within
this update.
JOANNA SMITH: So expect all
behavior to be the same.
Just look for it
in a new place.
And then the second question
that was posted was a little
bit off topic.
It's from Hans Moser.
And he wanted some advice
on his own app.
And for this, we don't really
have advice for particular
implementation details when
you're building an app.
But we do have a forum.
And Stack Overflow, we monitor
for specific questions.
So always feel free to go into
these to ask your peer group
for advice as well.
And then when you come down to
a particular problem, we'll
definitely be there to help
answer those questions.
But good luck, Hans.
And I hope you'll
use our forum.
And I'm just waiting for updates
if we have anymore.
GUS CLASS: So, yeah, we'll just
hang out for a few more
minutes and wait for any
questions on the event or on
the YouTube feed.
JOANNA SMITH: Yeah, we had a
really quick demo this time.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, a quick
demo this time.
It's short and sweet.
CHRIS CARTLAND: But maybe next
time, we should make the API
more difficult.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, that's
a good idea.
We'll make it really hard.
And then we'll have a really
long GDL session.
JOANNA SMITH: Hours.
Hours long, so all your
questions get in.
So, while we wait, I guess
I'll go over this week's
announcements, which are
actually really easy and short
and sweet as well.
Watch out for this
coming change.
That's my only announcement.
GUS CLASS: Yep.
JOANNA SMITH: It's a
pretty easy week.
GUS CLASS: Yep.
JOANNA SMITH: So let's--
we can always talk.
GUS CLASS: So, yeah, I mean,
these coming changes really
should not affect people's
apps in most cases.
The various things to be really
cognizant of are the
changes to albums and the
changes to articles.
If you've adjusted for changes
before along these lines,
there should really be just a
few minutes to less than an
hour to actually address
the updates.
JOANNA SMITH: And if you come
across a problem that's taking
you more than an hour maximum
to solve, you should be
posting and asking us questions
about what's going
on, Because we've all made
adjustments for these already,
and we've been able to do
them very, very quickly.
So, no questions
are coming in.
MALE SPEAKER: One question
on YouTube.
JOANNA SMITH: On YouTube?
CHRIS CARTLAND: So we just got
a question from YouTube?
JOANNA SMITH: Which is
still not showing up.
OK, here we go.
Gizem wants to create an app
that allows him to post on his
blog and have that show up
in his Google+ feed.
So this sounds like a great
feature request
for our issue tracker.
If you go to developers.googl
e.com/plus/support, you can
actually submit all of
your great ideas.
And I personally have to
go over all of them.
So, it's what I do after GDL.
So please give me all of
your feature requests.
Give me all of your ideas.
And I'll pass them along to the
right people and let you
know about their status.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Awesome.
JOANNA SMITH: And, of course, if
your question doesn't come
in by the time we end this
broadcast, we'll be checking
them over the next week to
be able to respond to any
follow-ups.
All right, I think
we can call it.
GUS CLASS: All right.
Thanks, everyone,
for watching.
JOANNA SMITH: And post
your questions.
I'll answer them later.
GUS CLASS: We'll see you
in the next GDL.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC PLAYING]